ja und du glaubst du wirst dich heute
richtig zoffen und zwar während der
streit im bundestag läuft mit
prominenten redner dort karl lauterbach
wolfgang kubicki und und gregor gysi
alle werden sie heute auflaufen zu
großen impfpflicht redeschlacht die
findet hier im studio dann auch stadt
mit dir und deinen gegnern die allesamt
dann für die impfpflicht votieren werden
also auch hier im studium mit dir klaus
heute in der regel nach der die band ist
sie dann dagegen was hast du dir
vorgenommen und das nach der separaten
sie dann dagegen ich bin ein großer
vielleicht träumer aber ich glaube dass
die stärkeren argumente überzeugend sind
und es macht doch nichts wenn jetzt
jemand in einer debatte ich zähle mich
dazu sagt ihre deine argumente haben
mich überzeugt und eins ist ja wichtig
letzte bemerkung wir haben ja in dieser
ganzen lästigen ätzenden pandemie phase
eins gelernt man passt seine
absichten seine ideen einer sich
dramatisch veränderten lagern deshalb
bisher immer dazu geführt dass alles
verschärft worden ist weil omikron delta
keine ahnung was jetzt ist es aber so
dass die entwicklung doch eindeutig
zeigt dass die impfpflicht die meiner
meinung nach noch nie verhältnismäßig
gewesen war jetzt aber angesichts der
omicron für läufe erst recht nicht im
verhältnismäßig ist und deshalb ist
meine forderung an alle die die
impfpflicht bisher richtig fanden geht
nochmal in euch denken sie noch mal nach
denn das was gestern möglicherweise bei
euch richtig war nicht bei mir könnt ihr
jetzt falsch sein und heute ist der tag
an dem es diskutiert dann los ab in die
redeschlacht mit dir du gegen die
impfpflicht und dein erster gegner kommt
hier klaus
und wir begrüßen ganz herzlich boris
palmer bei uns in der redeschlacht mit
claus strunz man kann eigentlich nur
sagen ring frei für die impfpflicht oder
gegen die impfpflicht eine debatte die
wir jetzt hier live austragen werden
die kosten mit hallo hallo herr palmer
herr strunz hat schon vorgelegt jetzt
hier plädoyer für die impfpflicht apa
ja das sind zwei völlig verschiedene
blickwinkel gibt auch strunz hat unser
gesinnungs ethische argumente
vorgetragen sehr grundsätzlich
prinzipielles ich bin eher ein anhänger
der verantwortungs edikt nicht
interessiert was sind die folgen unserer
entscheidungen übrigens tübingen
schreiben wir ohne h ein häufiger fehler
da bitte ich um korrektur für die
zukunft und die sache ist doch ziemlich
einfach wenn wir uns impfen haben wir 80
prozent weniger risiko dass wir ins
krankenhaus müssen hätte sich niemand
geimpft werde der impfstoff nicht
verfügbar hätten wir jetzt im ganzen
winter wieder lockdown herr strunz das
heißt nur weil so viele menschen
freiwillig das risiko dass der kleine
risiko auf sich genommen haben sich zu
impfen können wir jetzt wenigstens
einigermaßen normal leben in diesem
winter da geht es um große
freiheitsrechte da geht es um
grundrechte die ihnen bestimmt genauso
wichtig sind wie mir und ich möchte dass
wir jetzt ganz raus kommen aus diesen
beschränkungen dass diese maßnahmen die
auch immer unlogischer immer in
effektiver werden und das können wir nur
dann vertreten wenn wir sicher wissen
das wird nicht erneut zur überlastung
der krankenhäuser nicht dazu dass das
personal kündigt das den emigration
gehen dass krebs und herzinfarkt
patienten nicht mehr behandelt werden
können weil die kapazitäten nicht lassen
und sicher können wir da nur sein wenn
wir die impfquote der risikogruppe
hochbringen deswegen sage ich ganz
konkret alle über 50 müssen geimpft sein
dann ist schluss mit dem ganzen team ii
maßnahmen oder vereinfacht gesagt lassen
sie uns die hunderten von gar nicht mehr
verständlichen niemand mehr eingängigen
von gerichten bereits auch teilweise
verworfenen corona maßnahmen alle
streichen durch eine einzige regel
ersetzen alle ab 50 sind geimpft ich
finde dass wir damit als gesellschaft
einfach besser fahren und ich finde auch
dass dem bundestag zu steht eine solche
entscheidung für uns treffen
also sie haben mich richtig
interpretiert mit geht es natürlich auch
darum die grundrechte zu ihrem recht
kommen zu lassen ich finde dieses
argument einer
altersgrenze für die impfpflicht sehr
bedenkenswert das ist ja erst vor
einigen tagen in die große öffentliche
debatte gekommen gleichzeitig würde ich
sie die sie haben sich als
verantwortungsträger beschrieben ich
kenne sie wir kennen sie auch als großen
pragmatiker und dann lassen sie doch
einmal uns an der stelle sozusagen mit
unserem verhageln kurz innehalten und
sagen wenn es so kommt wie sie es sich
wünschen und wie ich sage dass es besser
nicht kommt auch bei den über 50
jährigen dann muss es regeln geben nach
denen man sanktioniert dann muss es
sozusagen
verhaltenskodizes geben die überprüft
werden dann muss es amtliche schreiben
geben mit bußgeldern die zugestellt
werden dann muss aber auch dafür sorge
getragen werden dass die bußgelder
eingetrieben werden wenn sie das in
tübingen zu organisieren hätten wie
würden sie das denn machen ohne eine
zweite stigmatisierung zu schaffen und
ohne daran zu scheitern denn wenn sie
damit scheitern würden dann wäre auch
die maßnahme die dem zugrunde liegt
wenig ernst zu nehmen
also erstmal würde ich gerne wert darauf
legen dass wir in deutschland versuchen
sollten stärker nach lösungen zu suchen
als nach problem denn sie haben jetzt da
sehr stark auf die was wäre dann das
machen sie wenn logik eingezahlt die in
deutschland zu verhindern die uns so
fesselt das ist eigentlich nicht mein
ansatz aber ich will da fragen nicht
ausweichen ich bin der überzeugung dass
die allermeisten leute wie sich jetzt
nicht impfen lassen sagen wenn es ein
gesetz gibt in dem eine impfpflicht
steht dann mache ich das zwar
widerwillig aber ich mache es das heißt
wir reden nur noch von der kleinen rest
zahl von menschen und für diesen
renitenten mein vater wasser bei einer
und diesen renitenten menschen darf man
sich die entscheidung nicht bestimmen
dass nach dem können wenn sie erstmal
nicht ausrichten und dann gibt es den
rechtsstaat wie würde ich das konkret
machen das relativ einfach es gibt ein
einwohnermelderegister man schreibt alle
einwohner an bitte schicken sie den
nachweis ihrer impfung dann wertet man
das aus wer keinen schickt krieg der
warnung und dann wird ein
bußgeldverfahren eingeleitet
was macht man bei verkehrsverstößen ohne
das ist jemand stigmatisiert das kann
man auch bei anderen bußgeldverfahren
genauso machen das ist kein hexenwerk
und in deutschland verwaltungstechnisch
jeder zeit umsetzbar das bedeutet aber
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe jetzt
nicht wenn dann und hätte hätte
fahrradkette
sollte es dazu kommen dass jemand diese
verpflichtung nicht nachkommt geht ins
gefängnis so ist es nämlich wenn man ein
bußgeld eine ordnungswidrigkeit oder gar
eine strafe nicht bezahlt das ist nur so
wenn ein richter das anordnete in der
regel so dass wahrscheinlich
verhältnismäßig sein da wird mir ja mal
ein zwangsgeld festsetzen und bis diese
fragen sich irgendwann einmal stellen da
sind jahre rum da arbeiten im bilde
justiz langsam meine prognose ist wir
haben in vier wochen 98 prozent der
risikogruppen geimpft wenn es die
impfpflicht gibt und dann haben wir noch
ein paar hundert fälle vor gericht da
können sie in drei jahren noch
schlagzeilen in der bilder mitmachen ist
aber nicht wesentlich ich will einmal
noch zurückkommen er sozusagen zu meinem
ausgangs argument nämlich der
verhältnismäßigkeit sie haben gefällt
das mäßigkeit auch bemüht allerdings
sozusagen für die andere these
verhältnismäßig ist etwas erst dann wenn
vorher alles andere ausprobiert und
gemacht worden ist und nichts gebracht
hat sind sie ernsthaft der meinung dass
die regierung die politik diejenigen die
dafür in verantwortung stehen wirklich
alles versucht haben um die menschen vor
der impfpflicht und ohne impfpflicht zum
impfen zu animieren
also vielleicht haben sie nicht das
beste marketing unternehmen engagiert da
kann man wahrscheinlich bei bild noch
was lernen wenn ich ihnen recht geben
diese plakate waren jetzt nicht sehr
eingängig aber ich kann ihnen berichten
dass wir in tübingen impfzentren
innerhalb von wenigen tagen auf die
beine gestellt haben dass es hier
kostenlose infektionen bei clubs in
partys bei ärzten gegeben hat dass die
honorare gespendet wurden für gute
zwecke dass man wirklich an jeder ecke
eine impfdosis abbekommen konnte hier
hat mich auf dem markt kinderarzt
angesprochen er hat noch eine biotech
übrig ob gerade jemand die haben will
dann saß einer da knallt und hat sie
genommen
also es gibt viel
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement und
ja ich behaupte wir haben in tübingen
echt alles angeboten wir hatten 1200
termine am tag zur verfügung zuletzt
waren noch 25 nachgefragt also das
angebot ist da die argumente sind auf
dem tisch endlich persönlich nämlich
sogar ein anspruch dass ich mit ungefähr
10.000 impfgegnern auf facebook herum
gestritten habe und jedes argument
vorgetragen hat ich persönlich bin der
überzeugung ganz ehrlich die sache ist
ausdiskutiert mit argumenten kommen wir
da nicht mehr weiter mal ein mail
eingang ist voll von menschen die
einfach nicht wahrhaben wollen dass die
impfung wirkt und mir was von bill gates
und chips erzählen das bringt uns nicht
mehr weiter deswegen sage ich ja auch in
dieser hinsicht ist es verhältnismäßig
sind jetzt an einem punkt wo diese
pandemie endlich mal zu einem ende
gebracht werden muss das kann der
impfstoff leisten ich würde ihnen einige
teile folgen in der conclusio nicht weil
ich fürchte wir impfen dann dem virus
immer hinterher das führt in eine
unübersichtliche wer gilt eigentlich
wann als geimpft es sind die
impfnebenwirkungen vor denen ich
persönlich keine angst habe ich bin
zweimal geimpft und gebucht hat das
bewegt aber viele leute noch nicht
ausreichend erforscht und ich halte es
wirklich für einen unverhältnismäßigen
eingriff in ein grundrecht und genau
deshalb werden wir an der stelle nicht
zueinander kommt aber verloren wir nicht
aber ein letzter satz war strunz ja ich
rede auch nicht von der dauer in split
also nicht jetzt alle drei monate zum
poster sollte meiner meinung nach
zweimal impfen und dann ist gut es geht
nur um die grundimmunisierung weil dann
hat man den schutz vor hospitalisierung
aber jetzt wir wollen und die kommen
aber die kommenden jahre bei der krippe
jeder kann für sich aber jetzt muss ich
sagen jetzt geht er jetzt geht der
pragmatiker politiker mit ihnen durch
das heißt jetzt impfpflicht problem vom
tisch
das heißt problem für die krankenhäuser
gelöst und dann kann es wieder völlig
eigenverantwortlich gehandhabt werden
weil dann keine überlastung mehr droht
ich will nur eine lösung für die
überlastung der krankenhäuser und danach
bitte wieder eigenverantwortung für alle
verstanden